hi i'm evan carmichael and today i'm
going to answer a question from one of
my readers christopher christopher is a
teenage entrepreneur he started a
company called bubble wear clothing and
it's clothing that has graffiti on the
front with a positive message and he's
trying to target the 13 to 25 year old
demographic and christopher's question
is should he be creating t-shirts with
graffiti on the front because there is a
stigma around graffiti
so my answer to you christopher and to
every other entrepreneur is don't worry
about the people who you're going to
offend you want to go after your your
target market so it's not going to
appeal to everybody but you want to make
sure that it appeals to the people who
you're actually trying to target so for
people who are 13 to 25 who like
graffiti your t-shirts have a positive
message those guys are gonna buy from
you and don't worry about trying to
please everybody usually when you try to
make everybody happy nobody's happy and
you don't end up making any sales so
make sure that people who are in your
demographic really love what you're
doing and don't worry about everybody
else
i hope that helps i'd love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment below the video and
please give it a thumbs up and we'll see
you on the next video